community brighton 8 new now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners
finley automotive group southwest
medical part of optum care
and silver state schools credit union
so what would we do without urgent care
especially
nowadays southwest medical the sponsor
of this next segment has several around
town making medical care convenient
for you and your family here's more
information
when should someone use urgent care so
urgent care is used when
perhaps you don't need the emergency
department
but you want to have something evaluated
the same day
for example a headache abdominal pain
your child has fallen and you're
wondering if they have a broken bone we
know everyone's lives are very busy
and coming soon to our on-demand
medicine department
is a feature called at home waiting room
you can log into
smalv.com and establish an account
and you will be able to actually check
in from home
and will be told your approximate
appointment time so you can arrive
shortly before that appointment
oh that's great so convenient and
speaking of convenient um now let's
let's go to convenient care and the
difference between the two
sure we also monday through friday from
eight to five have five locations that
are a convenient care setting
these provide some basic lab
testing including strap testing
pregnancy testing urine testing
they can also assist you with things
like sportsmen
sports physicals medication refills
and also some minor injuries as well
that's great and what about locations
are you guys across the valley are there
certain locations that you guys have
that you want to share
we actually have ten locations across
the valley
five of them are urgent care locations
four of those locations are open from
seven a.m to 7pm every day and our
rancho location at
rancho in charleston downtown near
university medical center
is actually open 24 hours for
convenience
so it's very nice when that child has a
fever in the middle of the night
or somebody comes in and they've scraped
their knee and you're really concerned
about a possible fracture
those are all great options for you our
convenient cares are
we have five of them scattered
throughout the valley those are located
um
uh in often our primary care centers
and those are open from eight to five
monday through friday
and dr joelson when should people bypass
urgent and convenient care and go
straight to er what are the signs
that's a great question so we typically
recommend
people go directly to the emergency room
or
call
difficulty 911 or moving a body part
or any chest pain that lasts longer than
five minutes and gets worse with
activity
if you're not having those symptoms we
would love to assist you
we have ashley onsite labs as well as
imaging including ultrasound cat scan
and x-ray at several of our locations
and we can often help you in a more
timely fashion in the emergency
department